[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Mary is
going to kick us off in Cleveland Ohio
Mary welcome to the
show Hi how are you doing today doing
well how are
you um I'm gonna be honest I'm a little
nervous and anxious right now we got you
Mary it's just us here just us girls
let's talk okay what's going on um so
I'm calling in because my husband is a
gambling addict and has been since
January of this year when it became
legal in
Ohio um it is call as the heaviest hole
on our marriage um on our relationship
our family and I'm at the point where I
have tried many routes with this trying
to be very gracious on how I go about it
trying to be respectful as a wife trying
to support his mistakes but trying to
get him the help he needs and nothing is
working um and at this point he is very
adamant about continuing to do it um and
I'm at the point where I feel that I
need to you know take my daughter and
take a step away not divorce but maybe
take some separation until he figures it
out but I honestly don't want to have to
do that but I don't know what else to do
right now what makes you think that or
what's happening that you feel like I
need to get me and my daughter out of
this to be
safe well um I think you're right I
think you're right by the way but I want
you just articulate what something else
is going on like what's happening in
your
home it's just an extremely tense
environment we argue all the time um
which you know we
wead are you arguing because he's losing
thousands and thousands of dollars or
arguing because he's just glued to his
phone all the time and he's angry
because he wins and loses or as Mo as is
most of the time the gambling Behavior
and the addictive actions that are keep
like this
compulsion um is indicative of a much
bigger issue in your marriage y'all
don't talk to each other you don't
listen to each other there's no intimacy
it's just become a mess and gambling is
the way he's choosing to handle that
that Global dysfunction inside your home
correct okay all of it um yes and I mean
the lying is the biggest thing so
anytime somebody has a boundary inside
of a marriage that they're thinking
about laying down right like this is
this is my um this is my final straw
this is my line that I won't cross
anymore I always want to encourage them
to have an or what statement because the
person they laid the boundary down um is
going to want to know can you give an
example yes so you need to have an or
what statement you sit down with your
husband and say if we don't go to
marriage counseling by the end of this
weekend or we don't have a date on the
calendar by the end of this weekend and
it's next
week and if you don't
go here's the or what me and our
daughter are moving
out okay period you just have to be
prepared for the or what because the or
what comes with a lot of complexity and
I know it sounds super cool to be like
you like you're G you can Google this
and on these stupid websites they're
going to tell you like just leave him
you don't deserve that sounds all well
and good but there is a significant
finding complexity to this
right yeah and I I mean I really don't
want it to have to come love him family
together of course you
do I want you to keep this front and
center As you move forward you are
simply doing what you have to do to keep
your family safe and responding to
somebody that's thrown a grenade inside
your
home yeah you're not the one doing this
and he will paint you as the villain
here he has that's right because he gets
to do whatever he wants to do whenever
he wants to do it with quote unquote
y'all's money and he can you're just
whining and nagging and complaining and
on
and online gambling online Sports
gambling is
destroying individuals and homes across
this country period and dude I always
watch the fights I love watching the
games I love having fun with my friends
so it's not that I'm like this fuddy ddy
that sits in my house and and plays
bingo the time I love I love the whole
environment and yet this is destroying
people yeah and you've told him that and
he has told you I don't really care what
you have to say I'm gonna keep doing
whatever I want to
do yeah and I mean it's it's been the
past few months um I guess to give just
some quick context uh so pretty much in
a lump sum he has spent between 30 to
$40,000 has he lost it
oh yeah like he's lost all all of it
okay we don't there there's no um I mean
he's you know won a couple thousand here
or 100 here things like that um but it's
it's he's all together um since the
beginning of this year it's been around
$40,000 um and can we be honest this is
what you know about I promise there's
more this is all I know about promise
more let me ask you some a very tactical
question if you move out do you have do
you have a job do you have
money um yes I I I have a job but
we um so he's in nursing school so hold
on hold on hold on he is making choices
you are keeping yourself
safe if he's in nursing school then he
gets to take care of his pay for nursing
he gets to make all those choices on his
own you need to have your four walls
covered for you and your baby if you
choose to do you have your own bank
account yes I actually did um probably
about two months ago at this point um
that was one of the steps I took was
separating good our finances we never
recommend that except in this moment
does it direct does your check direct
deposit into that account it's still in
our joint um and I will just say so
pretty much because we don't have any
like we don't have any Financial
Security right now so with my job and
his job we get paid each week so I get
paid and then he gets paid the following
and so on so forth so with our money
that we have right now I want to take
the money from like my check and put it
into ours but then all the bills come
out from our joint cuz we haven't
switched any of those yet so all of like
pretty much each paycheck that we get
each week is going towards bills going
towards groceries and gas and then
there's nothing left over I want you to
get with a friends and I want you to map
this out okay okay and you're gonna have
to move your direct deposit to your new
account and you know as well as I do
he's going to hit the roof isn't
he yeah he he already did when I I mean
everything I do he get he does that's
right are you safe
yes okay he's not going to hit you or
hurt you no okay so we are getting with
a friend and we're going to map this out
what's an apartment going to cost what
are the light and water bill going to
cost and we're going to get all this La
mapped out and lined out we're going to
make sure that our check can cover that
and you might need to get some new hours
and all that kind of stuff child care
all those things and then we're going
we're going to sit down and be very
articulate and clear about my or what
statement this
changes or here what I'm going to do you
can't control anything he does you can
only control what you do I hate that
you're in this situation stay on the
line we're going to hook you up with
every dollar so you can begin to control
what you can control if and when you
have to step away create your free every
dollar budget today the simplest way to
budget for your life